today is dr martin luther king jr day
normally there will be events held all
across the valley including the annual
parade downtown but
the pandemic has changed those plans
still people have found ways to honor
the
memory of the civil rights leader bianca
holman live this afternoon in the
historic west side of las vegas with the
story today bianca
this day might be a day off for some or
a moment to post
a quote on social media but for people
here at the vegas
community garden it was a day of action
to honor martin luther king jr it was a
call to service
and to serve the community the pandemic
impacted many traditional mlk events
but here at the vegas roots community
garden people planted healing herbs like
lavender thyme and cilantro
they were still able to participate in
the national day of service
the first planting is for health care
workers who serve
working-class communities of color in
north las vegas
the plots were also named after longtime
community activist
rudy duncan we've got a wide range of
people from a wide variety of
backgrounds
the diversity and the coming together
and i think that food
and gardening is the one thing that
unites us all so it's very important for
us to do an herb garden with
healing properties because we feel that
miss ruby has
encouraged and healed the community
throughout her decades of service
ruby duncan led 6 000 people in a march
for poor people's rights down las vegas
strip in the 70s
she was also instrumental in bringing
resources to nevada's black and working
poor communities
now the goal of the vegas roots
community garden is to nourish the
community
just like miss duncan did for decades
and also this community garden is open
to everyone
and they even have fresh produce for
purchase reporting from near tonopah and
bonanza
bianca holman 8 news now